welcome back to GameSpot presents the
mix right here at GDC 2015 I'm very
happy to be joined by two people this
time Tom happened da Mabel and thank you
so much okay and gents pleasure
has your GDC been the past hour or so
he's an enjoyment
oh it's been amazing two hours yeah you
already like 12 demo exactly all your
games yeah you're here actually just
show us two games and we're gonna talk
about actually on virgin a little bit
but first of all we've got chasm right
here your bad boy right yeah so I'm
working with the developers of chasm
they've been working on it before I got
involved probably about two years now
so I joint excuse me I joined the team
probably out four or five months ago you
were doing a digital suffer a Nintendo
before that's right yeah yeah so I was
ahead of the digital distribution
business at Nintendo for about nine
years
excellent then I left there in August
and wanted to work more closely with
indie developers so actually chasm and
axiom verge are like my two big projects
right now so thrilled that both games
are gonna be covered back-to-back
excellent we're gonna talk to Tom about
actually in virgin a little bit but
you're gonna feel driving now for chasm
so that's that let's jump right in and
tell us all about this bad boy so chasm
is as you can see it's got a very
distinctive pixel art art style lots of
shading lots of personality and it's
it's the premise of the game is that a
small mining town noticed that there are
some really weird things happening in
the mine in the town and so years are
always it I know mines are just always
violent tail over exactly and so the
army sends you to investigate and the
the beginning of the game takes place in
the mines and as you explore them and
then later on you uncover that more and
more kind of supernatural ancient
traditional stuff is going on so this
actually comes a little bit later in the
game this is the catacombs world and you
kind of uncover a little
about the mythology of the world this is
the lador II burial grounds
that are referred to cave paintings in
the mines this is quite a lot of that
lower stuff going on in absolutely so
there's very heavy RPG kind of elements
in the narrative oh prince of persia
PTSD is kicking in here exactly
yeah so there's definitely a lot of kind
of harkens back to a lot of traditions
but probably one of the biggest
distinguishing factors about this from
say you know a prince of persia back in
the day or another kind of exploration
based game is that each of the rooms
while you know hand designed the layouts
of each of the levels is all done
randomly each time so and each time you
play through you may not actually even
if you beat the game 100% you may not
actually see everything that there is in
the game because each world is is kind
of procedurally generated even though
the rooms themselves are hand design you
might see the same room different times
you play but you won't be able to say
okay I know I have to go left to get
this one potion or or to get this sword
and how is those safe stating stuff
working is this like a game where you'll
be playing for a couple of hours to
completion and then replaying it is this
a game where you'll you'll be dying
early and going back and starting from
the start again so yeah so there's a lot
of replayability in that even if you
beat the entire game that you're it's
worthwhile to play it again because you
get an entirely new map each time and
also there will be elements of the map
that you haven't seen the first
playthrough so definitely a lot of
replayability I would say one
playthrough the targets probably going
to be around somewhere around 10 hour oh
wow to play through the entire game
there's six worlds or six areas I should
say of the map and so this catacombs
level is one of them and let's see if
Tom if you could just call up the map
for a second so this you can see this is
like the first kind of conglomeration
yeah obvious is what we've seen with Tom
playing for the past week man exactly
and as he fills this out he'll get to a
checkpoint fairly soon and then he'll
take them to another kind of block of
rooms you can go back to the gameplay
and each of the worlds has I believe six
of those kind of groupings of everyone
so so there's about like 36 kind of
showing chunks of it yeah that you play
fen and whatever happens in that is
almost it's sort of the certain amount
of randomness exactly yeah tell us
little bit about the combat because that
was a really done interesting Sora fight
that happened earlier because it's funny
like I made the very bland comparison to
Prince of Persia which had the most like
they were games of all time tastic yeah
absolutely I think Jordan was actually
in TDC last year but the the combat not
obviously incredibly you know bland
sword fighting so what was happening
there looked incredibly interesting that
was a bit about different types of
combat is also we're seeing like and
we're seeing throwable items here and
exactly so if you'll notice on the left
side of the screen you've got this blue
kind of mana counter and all of the
projectile type weapons use use mana so
you can't just keep spamming that that
button and just throwing knives that
from a safe distance
but it's there if you if you want it
usually the X button there is for melee
combat also I don't know if you notice
but tom was able to get a little bit of
extra mana there you can pick a drink on
the way yeah and could you go to the the
inventory screen so you can see as I
mentioned earlier there's a lot of RPG
elements to the game so if you go to
equipment for example you can see what
is equipped to each each hand and and
also what armor you're wearing so that
will also influence a lot like Molotov
yeah so the magic Molotov is throwable
it you don't have to be it's kind of
like a grenade but you don't have to be
super precise
hit the stairs and it'll just spread or
its kind of hit whatever is in its way
but these are these skills that you are
discovering or ones that you're choosing
yourself your unlocks so the the
equipment is stuff that you acquire
throughout playing the game
there's also characters who appear in
the game that will sell you equipment
there's also some crafting that you can
do also if you find different gems
throughout the game you'll be able to
use those two crafting and have like a
fire blade for example and so I would
say probably everyone's play styles a
little bit different but I would say you
know about 80% of the game is melee
style rise combat and 20 the other 20%
is using those projectiles when you know
you're kind of in a pinch and you're
like you're low on health and you're
like this one character this one enemy
who always kills me I'm just gonna like
throw magic knives at him and he goes
away and you know make it to that next
checkpoint yeah I also appreciate
difficult platforming as well so it's
good to see that there is a degree of
skill required to walk around the chasms
themselves yeah there's actually oh oh
this is this is that checkpoint and if
you hit the select button again you can
kind of see like what one of those
chunks of rooms looks like so and so
this this is a you can replenish all of
your health and then go on to the next
chunk of rooms some of the rooms are
actually since you mentioned platforming
they're very platforming focus some
rooms are a lot more combat focused so
part of the algorithm of how these
worlds are procedurally laid out yeah is
it's actually in there to to make it so
that there's a balance of having a
certain amount of of areas that are
specifically what kind of combat focused
versus versus more platforming focus I
can here's a good example of the two of
them sort of being merged together yeah
an enemy and then a sort of an
environmental
something to try and get past it here we
have some spinning foam yeah what you
get now once you get to that this room
is one of those that's a lot more
platforming focused there's also some
where like there are these buckets that
are kind of floating around the room and
you've got a time your jumps and and get
onto those buckets let's see if you can
do this tom believe me you Tom yes yes
first try yeah that's whack yeah I must
be an interesting thing demoing a game
that has random levels yeah it's not
like I can say like yeah go to the right
and get that one powerup over there it's
super easy in practicing all morning
right yeah so then presumably the
enemies and wash some of the environment
elements they change between the
different zones exactly yeah so the
mines area where it's kind of
introducing the player to the mechanics
a lot of the enemies there are much
easier so you can attack them with your
sword and they won't chase you with old
us they'll be like Oh someone's hitting
me with a sword and just you know keep
going on their way whereas in this level
you're actually already encountering
enemies that will kind of pursue you
change their tactics a little bit they
also obviously do more damage if they
hit you so the difficulty keeps going up
the further into the game that you go
with the goal of where is this in
between the levels that you're
purchasing items or appreciative
purchasing skills yeah
so there's from time to time I have
pretty yeah and this actually I haven't
even talked about the puzzle element so
this actually this background here if
you can just go back to the mural press
B so if you notice there's a certain
number of stars that actually plays into
a puzzle later on where you've got to
know how many stars were on that mural
and things like that it's 9 right but I
came to mark 4 or 5 679 and actually and
each time you play through it'll be a
different number of stars so you can't
let us get to the gate take I already
know there's nine stars there cuz it'll
be different each time yeah you're just
ruining game facts yeah exactly yeah
there's no way to write a game facts for
this unfortunate yeah there'll probably
be some tips of like in general when
you're falling down a wall
stay to the right because there's you
know there's a chance that there will be
spikes in belief in between awesome yeah
so yeah there was something else I was
gonna mention I totally lost my train of
thought about I think it was something
about the oh we were feel sorry we were
talking about and the honor was at the
different types of enemies that are
within each levels yeah I can't wear
this gold gold yes I thank you
so God the Lord of the game one of the
things that you can do you'll get a this
kind of Falcon type bird I think it may
be a Phoenix
mmm that will take you back to the town
where you actually start the game and
there are places where you can buy
things there also later on you'll
thought there will be a merchant to who
joins in that save area and you'll be
able to find so this is a new enemy that
we haven't seen yet nice is there any
sort of new game+ stuff happening or
like a you know expert super difficult
mode yeah there's a hard mode and a
regular mode the hard mode is actually
much more like a roguelike where you get
I believe only one life and if you die
that's the end of the game and this demo
is actually kind of like that so if you
make it yeah well yeah yeah I think he's
running low on mana yeah and this guy
will charge you so you got to kind of
jump over them nice you get you get kind
of familiar with seeing the same the
same enemies over and over also at the
end of in each area there's a kind of a
mini boss and so and we'll see one of
those hopefully fairly soon I think Tom
we'll get to it and so there's a lot of
boss battles as well stay away from
those nasty porcupines it's good thing
there's no fall damage happening there
because there's lots of areas in this
game where you seem to be
search that the title screen vertically
coming down yeah there we go yeah this
is that oh yeah the Phoenix that you
that you get so they're also other
characters like the canary in the mine
almost yeah maybe maybe they should know
that
and so at whenever you get to a safe
point he'll actually fly you back to the
center of town if you need to there are
also other characters that you meet
throughout the game and if you can
rescue them from the mines they also
will come back to the town and you can
buy new things from I think you need to
go the right oair yeah and so yeah this
is unit to the boss battle you can tell
what it has not really foreboding here's
a bunch of mana and yeah I got things
ready something nasty is about to happen
alright gotta get ready
got your best loadout magic shield
I'd go at this field can I use this and
then switch later to the magic yeah I
think I think you can you should be able
to this is pretty hot but it would have
a is there like that and then yeah but
once you go into that room that it'll
have turned off so oh no did it mana
dump just a beauty of live demos it's
all right top we we know you can beat
this right that's cool you don't even
need to shield don't even worry about it
alright alright well okay no gentleman
said he died yeah so we're just not
gonna look at I did start though so
taking it seems like I'm not allowed to
use it let's say I'll go back to magic
knife yeah - life's always work on rates
oh he's got quite a lot of energy yeah
so the bosses generally do but like any
good boss battle the more you kind of
get used to the boss we kind of detect
the the certain patterns so this the
boss boss for all the mines section or
is this just the boss this is on the
catacombs area actually this isn't even
so mines
I believe there's there are a couple
basta this is considered a mini boss
it's not considered a major boss I mind
those candles burning you as well no
more background yeah it's the splash
from me are you almost gone as a half
house yeah you might need to drink one
of your health potions there soon
Oh sixteen yeah oh that's 16 now Thames
looking too hot yeah have a little drink
some of the drink where's inventory yet
weak health potion that's not a bud okay
it's better than nothing yeah I'm not
too weak as well it's okay considering I
guess what level the character is now
exactly yeah so you kind of like with a
typical RPG you do level up your
character over time and so as you level
up your your HP goes up your MP goes up
you also get potions along the way I
don't know if you noticed earlier but
Tom grabbed a potion that increased is
is MP by two okay
so you kind of get these power-ups more
and more as you go and to be fair to Tom
or this is actually he hasn't really had
a chance to practice like hey you're
gonna be demoing chasm so he's actually
I'm impressed with well you to return
the favor in a second in play average
right yeah I'd probably put in like 50
hours and it's actually fairly confident
I'll be able to do okay yeah I think you
want a beer yes I do a pretty great job
here 70 health though raised almost done
we believe in you the whole stream the
chach is screaming for you stay cautious
there you go get him get him nice oh
nice oh yeah
professional 200 gold
and a clapping production room as well
nice work when is a costume coming in
some platforms where we're currently
targeting summer so we just finished the
alpha release so this was backed on
Kickstarter so we put out the the alpha
build to all the Kickstarter backers got
a lot of really good feedback and so we
would didn't want to have any more
spoilers keep going out right so we said
all right this is the end of of the
alpha play test period now it's just
like we're gonna finish the game
excellent so that's we're currently
targeting summer first need to get it
fantastic nice work that's difficult to
do especially when somebody springs a
demo on yeah
you